Speaker 1: All right.
Let's now go to some stunning new polling
data which reveals that there could be a brutal
2024 election cycle coming for Republicans.
And it is all revealed thanks to a Fox News
poll.
Now, I want to remind people there's no hypocrisy
in saying Fox News content is agit trash that
should be flushed down the toilet.
But we can look at their polling.
Fox news polling is fine.
It's relatively well rated and it's generally
pretty well done.
You know, Fox doesn't do the polling itself,
just like CNN doesn't do its its own.
They hire a polling firm.
Okay, Check this out.
And this could really be a preview of what's
coming up.
Fox poll shows Republicans in for a brutal
2024 election.
Even Fox is admitting on air that the policies
it pushes aren't all that popular with voters.
They put up a poll and good for them for doing
it, showing how popular certain proposals
to try to mitigate gun violence are with the
American people.
And these are not shocking numbers to my audience
because we've been looking at similar polling
data for more than a decade since the Sandy
Hook shooting in Connecticut.
Background checks for guns, 87% of Americans
favor that.
And again, that means in all cases, even interpersonal
sales, all transactions must have a background
check, enforce existing gun laws, 81%.
You've got to be 21 to buy all guns.
That's not the law in a lot of places right
now, 81% ban assault weapons, 80% favor that,
and only 45% believe that more citizens should
be carrying guns.
This is yet another issue on which the right
wing media narrative has lost.
The average American Now, obviously, you go
to rural northern Indiana, where I've spent
some time and you ask people about these things,
very few people will want background checks
for guns and they'll mostly be against abortion.
Now, that's the other question that this poll
looked at.
Abortion should be 56% say legal and 43% say
illegal.
Now when you ask the question.
This way.
This is the split 56 to 43.
If you actually delve further into this and
you explain to people, 99% of abortions happened
before, I think it's 21 weeks.
And you explain more about the reality of
abortion.
You actually get even more support for abortion.
Just should just flat out be legal before
21 weeks.
And yet there are states that have passed
abortion bans far earlier than that.
So there's a few different things here that
I think are important to consider.
This isn't really newsworthy in the sense
that on policy, Republicans have been losing
for a long time.
In 2016, Trump eked out Hillary and it came
down to under 100,000 votes in three states.
But then, as the country continued to move
more to the left, it actually hurt Republicans
in election.
The 2018 midterms were not great for Republicans.
In 2020, they lost even more, including the
White House.
In 2022, it was going to be a red wave, and
yet the Democratic majority in the Senate
actually grew.
It's interesting to have a red wave where
Democrats gain seats in the Senate, although
they did lose the House and this all may be
culminating in 2024.
Now, I'm going to be doing some interesting
podcast appearances coming up.
And one of the things that I hope comes up
is what's at stake in 2024, because we have
another third of the Senate up for reelection,
as we do every two years.
That's always the case.
We have a presidential election, which may
well be a rematch between Joe Biden and Donald
Trump.
And we will have what I believe will be an
inflection point, a fork in the road, whatever
metaphor you want to use when it comes to
MAGA Trumpism.
MAGA Trumpism has hurt Republicans dramatically,
but it has hung on thanks to the likes of
Lauren Boebert, Marjorie Taylor GREENE and
some others maintaining their seats in the
House and elements of this in the Senate.
Lunatics like Josh Hawley and Ted Cruz.
Even though Trump insulted Cruz's wife.
Cruz has become a big Trump Trump ism, acolyte,
etc..
Republicans will decide in 2024, are we sticking
with this direction?
And potentially losing?
Or are we actually going to go in a different
direction altogether?
So a ton is up for grabs in 2024.
The Republican Party has made politics more
important for young people with the issue
of abortion.
This was the problem we always knew would
happen if Roe v Wade were repealed.
Yes, it would energize some people and they
will want and try to do even more.
But at the same time, you can no longer raise
money to try to overturn Roe v Wade.
You have to deal with the consequences of
it being gone.
And the Republican strategy has always been
to present themselves as an opposition to
some kind of evil.
Something scary.
Abortion through Roe v Wade mattered when
Roe v Wade was a thing.
You've got to keep the wedge issue to keep
voters scared so that they go out and vote
with you.
They won.
Now that issue has lots of its power.
Now I know that they've been saying, well,
now we need a federal ban on abortion.
It's fine that Roe v Wade was overturned,
but now we need to ban it, ban it outright,
federally, short lived, really unpopular idea.
It also wouldn't pass because we've got a
Democratic Senate.
So now they're saying, well, let's focus on
trans anti-woke, etc..
But the polling isn't looking great on that
either.
So increasingly they do need to try to steal
an election to win one.
Trump tried it in 2020 and it didn't work
and we have to make sure it doesn't work in
2024 either.
But a potential bloodbath for Republicans
coming up in what is now
just 18 months.
Incredible.